Memorial Day weekend moving on here
states moving to relaxed restrictions
many Americans will head to the water
for the unofficial start of summer this
weekend and beaches all around the
country will be open for business that
is despite the dangers from the
coronavirus rules vary very widely state
to state and Don Dahler is going to show
us some of the safety measures being
implemented ahead of the moral Day
weekend he's in Asbury Park along the
Jersey Shore and Don my little teddy was
wearing a stone Pony t-shirt just
yesterday getting it dirty at the
counter with dinner it's a great rock
venue there we were there last Memorial
Day weekend it's a wonderful place what
do you got there how are they keeping
people safe it is so wonderful the Stone
Pony is just that way by the way I drove
by it coming in great place great beach
and beaches like this one all up and
down the Jersey coast are getting ready
to open up for the long Memorial Day
weekend but with the rise of coronavirus
cases there are some who are still very
worried that this is all happening too
fast and too soon many beachfronts
across the country will be open for
leisure as restless Americans emerge
from their quarantine the boardwalks
been very crowded it's seen the beach
you can spread out a little more after
like 60 something days indoors it's nice
to soak up the Sun back on the beach in
California many beaches have already
reopened and pictures like these appear
to show some beach goers bending social
distancing guidelines New York will cap
Beach capacity at 50% and local
governments will require and enforce
masks use when social distancing is not
possible every coastal state aside from
Massachusetts Rhode Island and New
Hampshire will have at least some of
their Shores open to residents by today
New Jersey schoolteacher Kelly McAvoy is
picking up her summer beach tags but
remains skeptical on how social
distancing will work been really crowded
and a lot of people without masks so it
does make me a little nervous in one
southern New Jersey County volunteers
called social distance ambassadors will
patrol high traffic areas to remind
people to stay six feet apart it's
becoming safer for us to dip our toes
back into the water in this case
literally New Jersey Governor Phil
Murphy says encouraging kovat numbers
are driving his decision to reopen but
the economic numbers are anything but
one report says the state shore tourism
generated more than seven billion
dollars in 2018 but more than 1 million
people in New Jersey have filed for
unemployment since the pandemic began
and in April the state saw a loss of
more than two hundred thirty-six
thousand jobs in the leisure and
hospitality sector we really don't know
what to expect right now Asbury Park
beach safety supervisor Joe bond
Giovanni has been working this coast for
50 years most of the beaches are
limiting their capacities you know we're
in the same boat so we can follow our
social distancing rules and we'll just
have to play it by ear we've seen images
from other states of these crowds and
beaches that must be a nightmare
scenario for you well that's why we're
going to try to limit things so you know
we're not we're not gonna allow that to
happen here but when you say limited
what does that mean the police will get
involved and and break up crowds no
we're gonna have what we call social
monitoring people walking around to
remind people that they should be
separated we're not going to kick them
off the beach or have them arrest the
rain like that we just strongly advise
them against it
ironically some of the people most at
risk might be the ones who sit in these
lifeguard chairs you can see they're in
the process of switching the double
chair to the single chair because some
of the protocols to protect these
lifeguards are only one lifeguard in a
chair at a time must wear a mask and in
the event of a rescue they're allowed to
do the chest compressions but they can't
do the mouth-to-mouth resuscitation
we're told that there are EMT crews
nearby who could respond quickly in the
event of that need Gail
all right whatever it takes to stay safe
thank you very much John